hey guys welcome to DLM model
lifestyle I'm Nikita
I'm Daniel and today we are going  to show
you poses with an eye on facial
expressions because we're doing a
photo shoot for Daniel a new test for
some business suits yeah last time we did a
video where we focused on male model
poses for beginners but this time we're
going to focus on facial expressions so
I hope you guys can learn something if
you have not subscribed yet please do
say won't miss the next video
right here we go
first of all we're just gonna take some
serious photos of serious expressions
now you have to remember the three
different angles which I've explained in
the beginner video I'll add it here so
you can check it out if you take photos
of the suit the most important thing is
confidence so that's what we're
gonna show today so you have to have look
strong with your eyes right you can play
with your eyes brows you can go up or
down I'm gonna go up with my eye brows
little bit you can look straight into
the camera very strong
remember the angles this is 45 left
straight to the camera and left 45 now
these are all shots that I'm looking at
the camera but don't always look at the
camera look away from the camera all
right let's do a few where I just
look away from the camera
what adds a little bit of something
interesting is if your face looks the
one way and your eyes looks the other
way just a little bit to the side at the
photographer let me show you how that
looks like we're gonna do the other side
for you as well all right now we're
gonna do a little bit of friendly
smiling photos right the ones that they
love in commercials now the most
important thing that you need to
remember is that you need to smile with
your eyes your face will follow alright
so we're gonna start off just by being
friendly okay look at my eyes in this
shot
now we're gonna do a little bit of a
grin you know a cheeky grin alright so
now we're gonna smile a little bit more
all right now we're gonna show a little
bit of teeth all right now we're gonna
go for big smiles you have to make it
real don't fake it just be real just be
you give your smile how you would smile
okay you can play a little bit around
bring your hands up so that your face is
not alone alright guys so now you have
the basics of serious face the basics of
smiles and next is the basics of frowns
now some guys have a lot of different
kinds of frowns right so just bring
whatever you have for me and I don't
have a lot of frowns you know I can try
but there's nothing here
you know so I could try a lot of
different but styles but it's not working
so I'll give you what I have alright so
first off remember to bring your eye
brows
a little up and open your mouth a little bit
so that it looks more authentic
with the angles that you have the 45
left to the camera and 45 right
what looks sometimes really cool is if
you're looking down as well or up so I'm
gonna add that with the frowns so I've
explained the basics of just looking
serious the basics of smiles and the
basics of frowns right so next up is cool
I know it sounds strange but some of the
photographers especially in the east they can
ask you too it too look cool give a cool
look  so what you can do is
you can have a normal cool look which looks almost a
little bit angry and the second one
is you just look cool where you kind of
grin and have a kind of naughty look alright so
let's do those two okay remember your
eyes right your face will follow
you can add frowns in the cool look as well
now there's another look another look that I
personally do not like  at all but that's
the kind of look where they don't want
you to give any expression to you look
kind of dead right well especially with
the young models that is what is in
right now I kind of really don't like it
but okay that's just my... okay anyway
let's move on so the next
basic style is going to be the style
where you show basically kind of nothing
right
for some people it looks cool so that's
what they're going for so it's gonna be
a cool slash no expression feel okay
let's do that it looks really
interesting if you tilt your head a
little bit or make it look kind of cool
weird interesting so let's tilt the head
so you can see how that looks like
I call this the whatever look you know
it's just like whatever
the worst mistake new models make is that they think cool
is narrowing your eyes is this one
see that kind of expression if you do
that the whole time it does look it's
some clients might dig it they might
like it but you cannot use the same
expression all the time all right so now
let's just freestyle and just play around a
little bit with expressions with the
angles let's go for it
should I go slower all right sorry we're
focusing on...  all right I'll go slower
okay that's it that's enough Nikita come
here guys thank you so much that is the
end of the video thank you for watching
Thank You Nikita for the new photos that
I have for my portfolio
I'll add a link to her portfolio so you
can check out her works she is an awesome
photographer and if you have not
subscribed to my channel yet please do
so you won't miss the next video that's
it thanks guys yeah see you in the
next video
If you haven't subscribed yet please do so
you see the next video...jkskds
okay three two one
hey guys welcome to DLM model Lifestyle...